c'est son fils mme son fils unique
[Musique]
je veux savoir qui a appuyé sur la
détente qui a tué mon fils
on a dépensé énormément de temps
[Applaudissements]
d'argent et d'énergie
pour que justice soit faite pas
suffisamment je pense qu'il faut une
approche différente
il faut agir de l'intérieur
ces messieurs je vous présente notre
nouvelle recrue
je vous mentirais pas ça peut être
dangereux de sa vie a aucune valeur pour
nous il déconne pas je m'en occupe c'est
tout le pognon et jeté le à la rigueur
vas-y fais ce qui te demande
tiens
l'effectif total
pour qui tu passe peut être permettre
croco nord a dit quoi jeter du vote lui
c'est pas un des suspects habituels est
ce que vous voulez qu'on fasse je peux
faire en deux semaines ce que vous
aimeriez faire en cinq ans
je veux un nom
du genre à faire ça
si on est capable
je vais pas en place
je suis un homme en colère
et
si c'est parfait c'est quoi
une [ __ ] dame noire